welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and secret Invasion heavily implied
that James Rhodes war machine has been
at least recently a scroll episode 3
ended with Nick Fury scroll wife Vara
AKA Priscilla taking a secretive phone
call that Fury somehow sensed was a
scroll high up in the US government and
the episode ended with Don cheadle's
unmistakable voice over the phone to her
St James Church one hour
I need to speak to graphic yeah well
you're talking to me now while this is
just rhody's voice and he might still be
in his human form just In Cahoots with
graphic and Priscilla for him to be a
link in the chain between Fury squirrel
wife and the squirrel General Graphics
suggests very strongly that James Rhodes
is himself currently a scroll but for
how long to help me break down the
timeline of when we were with Rudy and
when it was scruty welcome our inside
Marvel co-host and secret Invasion comic
expert Hector Navarro man I tell you
what this scrotie has got me itching
Eric we gotta get to the bottom of the
oh do you regret naming him scrotie well
we're gonna go with it let's figure out
when scrotie became scrotie
I'm also reminded that new rockstars is
now three channels this main channel
three straight breakdowns deep dive for
special film analyzes for me and the
break room where you can find our secret
evasion after show where Hector is on
every week subscribe to all three and
support our network with our squirrel
inspired shirt from our nerd riot.shop
all right let's get started okay if
Roadie has been a scroll we have have to
assume that he was at least a scroll in
every instance of secret Invasion thus
far including in episode 2 when he met
with Nick Fury so how long have you
known about them about 15 years ago I
was part of an
Eyes Only top secret presentation it's
about a shape-shifting alien species
that had sent a few of its light ships
crashing down to earth the Pentagon was
concerned that they might get into their
heads to invade us one day from the
inside Nick Fury says that the invasion
is real it's happened and Roadie takes a
beat to say that's
that's not possible now we have to
assume that the scroll form of roadie
might just be dismayed that Fury now
knows about this or scrotie might be
refuting the Pentagon paranoia that
squirrels actually get inside our heads
as part of this Invasion like to some
squirrels that might be a
mischaracterization of what is actually
happening squirty might just be a
government liaison trying to keep the
peace with gravic but Hector I don't
know if you caught this in this episode
2 scene there was a glowing green
exercise over rhodey's head the color
green everywhere in this series The
signify scroll but my issue with scrotie
I brought this up before is that for him
to be a squirrel the whole time might
just redefine too many of these great
MCU moments you're absolutely right so
let's look at those moments let's go
back to the first Iron Man this movie
took place in either 2008 or 2010
depending on what you're looking at and
here he was played by Terence Howard and
no he isn't a scroll just because he
character was recast relax okay Don
Cheadle was just the next actor to play
the same character here Roadie was
probably safe Iron Man 2 took place in
2011 about a year before the Avengers
Roadie here appears on Tony's side at
the Senate hearing making a joke about
the recasting this would be when Rhodey
would have received that Pentagon
briefing about Scrolls or maybe even
before the events of the first Iron Man
movie if that film was officially moved
up to the timeline six months before
Iron Man 2 as the opening of Iron Man 2
declares I guess we won't know for sure
until the MCU timelines book comes out
later this year pre-order your copy now
and be ready to get an update to that
book because Marvel's dude is always
changing that timeline that's true
sorority returns at Iron Man 3 and that
takes place at the end of 2012 I believe
six months after the battle of New York
Roadie at this point is now serving as
the Iron Patriot hero he's helping
rescue president Matthew Ellis from
replied by Alter Killian's aim Rudy also
returns in Age of Ultron helping the
Avengers celebrate defeating Hydra
helping rescue the sokovians of that
movie defeating Ultron and becoming a
fully fledged Avenger by the end of the
movie but I think in these films Rudy
really did nothing scroll suspicious
Everything Changes in Civil War Rhodey
gets injured in that airport battle he's
incapacitated he survives he gets some
surgery and he ends that movie in
physical therapy walking with these leg
braces but this period is crucial the
rodeo gets injured and the battle must
have been human if a squirrel had taken
that injury when he passed out he
probably would have reverted to a scroll
form he would have been bleeding some
purple everybody's got bad habits and
there's nothing wrong with habits it's
just the bad habits that are bad when
you're in the mood for Redemption Arc
turn your bad habits into good ones with
fume fume is an innovated
award-nominated device that helps you
turn your bad habits into good ones
there's no electronics no Vapor no
harmful chemicals fume is completely
natural and uses all natural ingredients
to give you a burst of delicious
flavored air this is where the core goes
into I'm just opening back a pack of
course here
um yeah yeah it's just a very pleasant
scent it doesn't like take you out of
the moment it just kind of lets you
settle into it see instead of bad fume
is good it's a habit that you're free to
enjoy and makes replacing your bad habit
easy Doom comes with adjustable airflow
dial and is designed with movable Parts
magnets it's super fidgety which is
perfect for de-stressing and anxiety
while breaking your bad habits using a
fume is like having a breath of fresh
minty air coming out of your new
favorite fidget toy switch in a few is
easy over 100 000 people have used fume
to successfully break out of bad habits
and now you can too head to tryfume.com
and use code new rockstars to save 10
off when you get the journey pack today
that's tryfum.com and use code new
rockstars to save an additional 10 off
your order today so if we're talking
about Roadie getting swapped at all it
would have had to have happened after
this point so then cut to two years
later in Avengers Infinity War Roady
survives the snap and joins the other
Avengers in the Captain Marvel
mid-credits scene could this Roadie have
been a scroll it's been two years like
we were saying Roadie has recovered but
what if a scroll replaced him and used
their more enhanced durability to
recover faster then you get to Avengers
end game Roadie spends time with the
Avengers during the blip helps with the
Time Heist and Witnesses the death of
his best friend Tony Stark if this was a
scroll he's the best damn scroll actor
in the history of scrollos and then we
gotta mention the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier which took place in 2024 a few
months after end game here Roadie meets
with Sam Wilson in the Smithsonian to
talk about the responsibilities of being
an Avenger and it's a performance that
won Don Cheadle and Emmy nomination for
outstanding guest actor in a drama
series that he was surprised that too
Don Cheadle it's great now Marvel has
announced a future title armor Wars
which will be a film starring Don
Cheadle we've got to assume that the
Roadie of this film will be the real
Roadie because I just don't think the
studio will expect the average viewers
the second and third weekend fans to
know that the Don Cheadle starring in
this movie is an extraterrestrial
shapeshifter top of all that that'd be a
wild trailer let me tell you that would
be so wild if that's what they did maybe
I'm just an old sentimental such and
such Eric but my theory is that Roadie
was replaced after the events of
Avengers endgame and maybe even the
events of the Falcon and the winter
soldiers simply because I can't see
Marvel Studios ripping those emotional
moments away from fans I completely
agree Hector Marvel Studios has just
been so careful when it comes to the
events of Avengers end game to avoid
changing any of the context of what
those characters were going through in
that Epic Epic film if Rhodey had been
swapped out for a scroll during or after
the events of civil war that would mean
it was a squirrel who traveled back in
time with the Avengers a scroll loop
identificated on killing Thanos as a
baby a squirrel who cried at Tony side
upon his death but when you come back to
actually watch the Falcon the Winter
Soldier scene what exactly does Brody
say to Sam let's check it out world's a
crazy place right now allies are now
enemies alliances are all
torn apart the world's broken
everybody's just looking for somebody to
fix it yeah yeah then they stop in front
of caps uniform and shield and Roadies
tell Sam it it's a new day brother I
don't know it's not the craziest couple
of lines to redefine is something a
scroll might say yeah and while Marvel
Studios might consider Roadie an in-game
to be Untouchable his cameo in the
Falcon Winter Soldier while Emmy
nominated I think might still be free to
retcon I think you might be right but if
Roadie were swapped out by a scroll
before his talk with Sam Wilson the new
Captain America it would shed a
completely new light on those
conversations makes me want to go back
and re-watch those scenes in the first
episode to try and pick up where the
scroll agenda might come into play did
scrotie try and deter Sam from picking
up the shield because gravic and his
forces are wary of the symbolic power of
Captain America or did scrotie want to
convince Sam Wilson to wield this shield
for other scroll reasons we aren't
seeing yet that is an interesting Theory
Hector like think about it he's talking
about how the world no one knows what
side anyone is on it's a crazy place
right now and the only person who could
restore order that would be a Captain
America and without a Captain America it
makes the Scrolls plot even easy here so
for now I'm comfortable saying Brody was
Roadie during endgame yeah but either
just before or sometime just after the
Falcon Winter Soldier Rudy was kidnapped
and supplanted with a scroll a scroll we
will call scrotie scrotie agree boom
you're looking for this scratch that
itch scrotie
oh I'm gonna have fun saying that hey
subscribe to all three of our channels
new rockstars the break room in the Deep
dive and support us by grabbing some
merch at nerdright.shop let us know what
you think about scrotie's timeline and
whether this is a recent thing or
whether he could have been a scrolled
the whole time the whole time follow me
at EA Vos follow Hector Hector is funny
and at Heroes reforged thanks for
watching everyone and I'll see you next
time bye Hector bye egg
[Music]
thank you